se croit prostitution violence islam
il ya de nouvelles révélations sur les
dessous de la télé réalité on va tout
vous dire sur notre nouveau dans notre
bouée séquence ces zones exclusives
c'est parti dans franchement on a des
infos de ouf parce qu'il se passe des
trucs de ouf on se demande à l'arrêt en
télé aujourd'hui tous les jours il ya
toujours un scandale
alors est ce que c'est vrai est ce que
c'est faux vous allez nous dire tout ça
et guillaume genton a enquêté
c'est parti on y va ces journées qui
suivent on y va c'est parti ici alors on
va avoir dans un instant et media markt
qui va balancer sur les coulisses de la
télé réalité elle a participé à fun ce
trip 2 et 3 sur nrj 12 est aux anges 9
alors déjà la première partie notre
enquête concerne la drogue avec de
nouvelles révélations exclusives qui
sort demain dans le magazine public
julien baer des marseillais et des anges
qui serait impliqué dans une affaire de
trafic de drogue
regarde connu grâce à ses participations
à beaucoup d'émissions de téléréalité
dont les marseillais julien baer est
aujourd'hui dans la tourmente suite à de
lourdes accusations à son encontre
le candidat est accusé d'avoir participé
en 2015 un trafic de drogue de grande
envergure selon le magazine public la
police le soupçonne d'avoir transporté
des valises remplies de drogue à
l'aéroport de punta cana
s'il a été entendu récemment pour cette
affaire les accusations ne sont pas
nouvelles
il s'était déjà exprimé à ce sujet
clamant son innocence j'ai connu des
gens dans le milieu de la nuit à paris
on sortait souvent mais je ne savais pas
ce qu'il faisait on s'appelait
régulièrement et on m'a pris pour l'un
d'eux j'ai été soupçonné d' importation
et détention de stupéfiants à
l'international une version qui n'a
visiblement pas tout à fait convaincu la
police
jean-michel je la trouve je trouvais
nous est très jolie je ne connaissais
pas merci basse et basse il va tout cas
bon alors je vois depuis j'adore c'est
un tarissement nova il est bon mais en
tout cas c'est très sympa coup c'est
sympa que vous dites c'est ça merci en
tout cas merci d'être là alors il a
participé aux anges 9 wayne ce trip 2 et
3 sur nrj 12
mais pour l'instant on est sur julien
baer julien baer dont qui était l'un des
candidats des plus l'un des plus
sulfureux des anges 6 il avait giflé
frédéric avec son sexe la vidéo a été
supprimée
non mais ça fait pas rire a réuni les
anciens candidats raconte les faits
regardez c'est ça serait jugée alors
julien blond à horaires jeudi aurait
biffle et frédéric l'intendante n'ont
pas vraiment on peut pas dire qu'il a
tort parce qu'il a posés oui mais posé
son ce que nous avait sont servis tout à
ce qui est dit on a entendu parler
vanille et de soda et bien sûr ma prix
là et là bas il n'a pas plus fait qu
elle aussi mais non identiques à celui
là tu sais quand tu as vu quand tu fais
la photo pour la presse depuis son
sommet que avec le camion avec le cadet
pour ange bas c'est ce qu'a fait une
photo en mode alors benjamin castaldi on
le voit y at il de la drogue dans la
téléralité dans l' effet beaucoup de la
vérité ce qui est de la drogue circule
c'était là les verts je connais pas je
sais quelle époque de 2,6 crête on a
découvert ça c'était en tout cas c'était
une priorité toute la vérité je voudrais
pas été c'est évidemment à une priorité
pour les producteurs d'éviter qui en est
on à découvert à nu un trafic et voilà
un trafic dans la love ça dans la maison
en fait le y avait un système de
blanchisserie et on a découvert que la
drogue rentrer dans les cols de chemise
non bon après on l'a découvert on l'a
arrêté
mais c'est vrai que c'est la seule
angoisse numéro un dans dans ses
émissions là où il y avait de la drogue
ya ba oui sauf fois comme drogue la
vérité dans la drogue note a2 de câline
largué dans les cols de chemise collège
colbert
c'est sûr que c'était pas le truc pour
le col dur mais voilà ça pour le coup
ils feront ils sont extrêmement prudents
mais malheureusement les mecs il a avalé
des tonnes à l'ayraultport c'est
pourtant dans une maison puisque c'est
facile dr la drogue donc dans cet arbre
dans la traque et alors
j'oubliais avaya il dit qui a participé
à secretstory aux anges qui parle lui de
sa consommation de drogue sans complexe
il l'a dit au youtube heures samedi rats
chez certains candidats aussi la drogue
mélange à l'alcool et au mal-être
peuvent conduire au pire comme avec
loana qui a fait plusieurs tentatives de
suicide
ce qu'elle a dit et il ya morgan aussi
qui a participé à la cinquième saison de
secret story qui balance sur la
production
elle révèle que la prod lui a demandé de
mentir à la psychologue de l'émission
notamment sur sa consommation de drogues
et ça c'est un extrait que je voudrais
montrer très ça c'est fou ça c'est vrai
alors oui vous allez nous dire après si
c'est bon tout les pour passer un
entretien psychologique mais ce qui se
passe c'est que les casteurs nous disent
de mentiras psychologue mais moi j'ai
envie de mentir donc je vais dire on
écoute et on m'a dit pas vous lisez nos
mais voilà j'ai déjà pris de la drogue
dans ma vie c'est fini depuis longtemps
mais au moins est halal s'est indignée
elle m'a dit croire comment mais c'est
pas normal qu'on vous dise de mentir bas
au final on a continué à discuter
elle a quand même validé ma candidature
et elle a continué à travailler avec
endemol
voilà alors les vols c'est la boîte la
boîte de production alors est ce qu il
ya de la drogue jeu des infos la guilde
si vous avez julien berges peu voire
très bien à lui donc lui il avait fait
96 heures de garde à vue ce qui est
énorme et il lui était reproché d'avoir
traîné avec des gens qui importait de la
cocaïne en france aujourd'hui
il connaîtra son sort judiciaire on mais
il espère du sursis il a 27 ans il est
là deux entreprises aujourd'hui
alors il n'ya plus que ce chef de mise
en examen d'association de malfaiteurs
parce qu'il a demandé lui même à faire
des analyses toxicologiques et il a
prouvé qu'il n'avait pas consommé
lui-même d'accord donc ça à alléger et
il espère qu'elle ne sera qu on à dire
bien sûr si benjamin castaldi donc vous
le dites par exemple serré où leur
demande de mentir pas la maison c'est le
grand problème c'est pour un casteur est
pour quand on fait une émission il ya
des clients qui sont excellents et on
sait qu'il ya des barrages en théorie
qui sont un psychologue et ils
connaissent bien les ce qui peut faire
en sorte que le psychologue met un avis
négatif
donc on peut conseiller et évite de dire
si ou ça c'est vrai pas vous mentir
c'est la vérité voilà alors c'est aussi
un concept parfois certains candidats
rentrent dans des émissions et qui sont
fragiles et que parfois il ya des
débordements voilà il ya un autre
scandale kyle busch éclaboussé le monde
de la télé réalité d'ancienne candidate
aurait rejoint des réseaux de
prostitution pour gagner des grosses
sommes d'argent ou vous a résumé les
faits ça aussi il faut que vous allez
nous dire la vérité benjamin castaldi
est émis
qui est avec nous également il nous
dirait si c'est vrai si c'est faux et
c'est chez emi a failli caler chez
sephora regardez plutôt dark depuis
plusieurs années les polémiques se
multiplient autour des rapprochements
entre télé réalité et prostitution de
nombreux candidats seraient mêlés de
près ou de loin ce type de pratiques qui
seraient légion dans le milieu la
candidate de fresnes streep amy les
amarres avait balancé il ya quelques
temps dans une vidéo sur internet
aujourd'hui tu peux nous confirmer qu'il
ya de la prostitution 21 pays bien sûr
que oui
on lui aurait proposé à plusieurs
reprises des rapports tarifés l'émission
les terriens du dimanche avait également
réalisé un reportage sur le sujet il ya
quelques temps à l'époque une candidate
avait accepté de témoigner anonymement
avec 15000 euros donc pour l'associer à
bas j'aurais pété plus je pense qu'il
avait fait autre chose ça les choque de
voir 2
des collègues en fait des chèques qui
j'ai partagé des tournages se livrer à
ce genre de pratiques
elle s'adonne même instant confiné des
pratiques qui aujourd'hui encore serait
courante dans le petit milieu de la télé
réalité
alors il ya une ancienne candidate de
sic à témoigner de manière anonyme à
l'accusé une autre figure de la télé
réalité d'être à la tête d'un important
réseau de prostitution
regardez et juste après benjamin vous
dire la vérité également et me dit vous
voyez 15000 euros donc pour la semaine
la barre j'aurais pété plus je pense
qu'il avait fait autre chose
elle s'adonne menace tantôt fini c'est à
dire que pour une somme encore plus
élevé elles vont jusqu'à se faire
déféquer au visage ça se passe où
famille dans la ville a en fait dans la
salle de bain à villa il y à la mère
maquerelle et elle recruta dès qu'il ya
une petite saveur vivante une nouvelle
recrue talent elle était plutôt sexy
elle recruta pour pour la vendre et
pourquoi prenez comme sur elle en fait
mais commission alors c'est grave
ben voilà c'est ce cas là je connais pas
précisément mais en tous les cas ce qui
est sûr c'est que dans les démissions
votre j'ai animé on s'est rendu compte
que certaines candidates avaient un
passé de call-girls auxerre du conte
comment parce qu'effectivement ces
fumées 24/24 qu'elle parlait dans une
langue étrangère
on s'est douté qu'ils avaient quelque
chose on a compris très vite que
certaines mains voila aparté
effectivement dans des pays à plus tard
dans le c'est devenu le code dubaï où
effectivement on savait très bien que
certaines femmes et avait une double vie
en sommes voilà faisait ce métier et
même certaines disait parce que vu ce
que ce faire comme pognon ça commence à
me saouler de rester avec vous donc
c'est donc je vous dis donc
effectivement c'était alors prêt ni la
chaîne ni les producteurs ni moi voilà
on est chacun fait ce qu'il veut c'est
un métier comme métier comme les autres
mais c'est vrai que c'est vrai que dans
la télé réalité de plus en plus et plus
on a avancé dans les années et plus les
candidates avaient un double métier quoi
moi ce qui me rend fou je le dis à
christine kelly je dis la vérité
moi moi ce qui est fou c'est nous le
sait ça ils nous ont demandé 3 millions
d'euros il nous lâche pas dès qu'on dit
à un truc et il se passe des trucs comme
ça dans des émissions je n'ai jamais vu
un truc mais une émission de télé abc
rive nord où il aurait même assez rare
et et c'est n'importe quoi parce qu'on
va parler des bagarres de la violence
tous à ce qu'on peut voir franchement là
les mecs il faut
arrêté parce que même si c'est hors
antenne je suis désolé je suis désolé
c'est inadmissible les marseillais
lévis la villa des coeurs brisés l'aïe a
gagné de la tentation qui arrive à ça ça
va être pire je suis désolé l'ancien
solidien cir alors vous n'êtes rios est
absolument d'accord avec vous d'ailleurs
j'en ai discuté avec des gens des
services du csa et qui en off m'ont dit
qu'effectivement ils sont choqués
surpris non mes devoirs qui n'ont pas
les moyens d'enquêter sur ce qui se
passe derrière ils n'ont malheureusement
la loi veut qu'ils ne s'occupent que
ceci se passe à l'antenne et pas
derrière alors que derrière il ya
beaucoup de choses à apprendre beaucoup
de mergieux beaucoup de trucage beaucoup
de trafic
mais malheureusement ils n'ont pas
autorité pour alain jura avait
compétence mais c'est grave franchement
c'est grave jean michel jeanne discuter
des défis de territet qui sont très
sympathiques au demeurant mais qui
magique de façon très cash que c'est le
faisait la terre réalité ce n'est pas
pour faire après de la télévision un
métier c'est seulement pour augmenter
leur valeur financière en tant qu à ce
corps tu sais qu'à parfois elles sont
connues elles valent rien coup plus
chers à l'exportation
les géographes certains pays dit je veux
celle ci puisqu'elle avait connu à la
télévision la télévision alors justement
je vais me tourner vers émis parce que
vous avez eu depuis tout à l'heure vous
avez dit d'accord avec tout ce qui se
dit donc vous nous confirmez drogue dans
la télé réalité
oui totalement et en plus de ça la
drogue moi par exemple j'ai fait des
anges des frênes scream 2 et 3
nrj12 et la production ne le savez savez
qu'on ce que la plupart prenez des
drogues
le staff nous accompagnait aller
chercher nos drogues donc c'est pour ça
que je ne parte on ne contredit pas
benjamin mais je pense que vraiment
c'est grave ce qu'on dit fabrique en
plus c'est des productions très sérieuse
mais c'est de donner à l'extérieur où on
a une séquence la bombe dépêche toi vas
chercher mais des pêches non c'est ça
leur est alors la prostitution vous
dites c'est déjà ça c'était cet eee
franchement là le csa c'est incroyable
je sais ça qu'est ce qu'ils font mais
non mais non mais c'est là où je suis
d'accord aussi avec vous c'est que le
csa malheureusement et parfois enfermés
navale et les infos on ne va pas les
voir pour leur donner raison
non des lancers au leur dire franchement
il ya plein de jeunes qui regardent ça
je suis désolé qu'ils veulent participer
de la télé réalité si on te vend dans
une télé réalité on se drogue
on se prostituent mais ces onze par sa
livrée qu'il faut arrêter ça ah oui
désolé vous êtes vous étiez vous aviez
l'air aussi d'accord sur la sur la
prostitution où il bien sûr mais la
plupart sont déjà défi qui est faisait
ça avant et le savent aussi
on en parle beaucoup en tournage on le
dit à la production comprends pas parce
que on est automatiquement associés à
ces personnes là et donc il le fallait
ils ferment les yeux nous bon discret
ces religieux parce que le casting est
bon c'est american fournier - c'est le
cas simon sont les personnages alors moi
je vous dis bien de moi ça alors je le
dis je suis je suis n'arrive ça me rend
fou franchement nous on nous emmerdent
toute la journée 1-1 alors on fait une
émission je le dis et je le pense
vraiment avec de très belles valeurs
voilà et les autres émissions je vous
dis pas qu'il faut les sanctionner
mais mine de rien voilà c'est vrai ici
c'est incroyable franchement c'est
incroyable de voir ça désolé je vais en
parler on a parlé avec eux avec
christine la grosse angoisse de tf1 à
mon époque c'était que le csa justement
mettent le moins de 12 parce que si on
met loin 12 ça peut plus passer à 19h
sur ça pour le coup il en avait été
question ça n'a pas été fait mais
c'était la grande angoisse au tfh quand
il est très attention qui coupait qui
bipent etc
c'est quelque chose je suis retrouvé que
les versions de télé réalité extérieure
était quand même plus en plus violentes
dans les menant les gestes et dans les
paroles que kirk en vélo justement on va
parler de la violence parce que dans
l'émission zéro complexe pour taire 24
vous êtes apparue avec un oeil au beurre
noir
mais qu'est ce qui s'était passé en fait
mais durant une sortie en boîte de nuit
une candidate
on a eu un petit accrochage elle m'a mis
à une droite et voilà et la production à
la baisse a prévenu
mais la production n'a pas su arrêter ça
en fait il était pris de court et on
essaie voilà ils ont laissé les choses
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de violence et
nos voix l'antenne puisque de nombreuses
bagarres ont éclaté au coeur de des
émissions on a on a fait voilà alors est
ce qu'ils font ça pour faire parler
d'eux ou voilà oui parce qu'ils savent
pas ce que sont vraiment énervé regardez
vous à faire un petit récap de quelques
affaires assez violente dans la télé
réalité
voilà ça concerne tous ça concerne aussi
bien la villa
les marseillais que les anges de la télé
réalité on le sait le clash est une
tradition mais ces bagarres parfois
exagérés sont tout de même le reflet de
vives tensions et de réelles règlements
de compte qui parfois dégénèrent en
violences entre des candidats chauffé à
blanc prêt à tout pour faire le buzz ces
dernières années les altercations
éclatent dans ce type d'émission se sont
multipliées ces violences sont la
plupart du temps visible à l'antenne il
arrive parfois que ces échanges musclés
et lieu également à l'écart des caméras
des débordements qui ont parfois mené à
l'exclusion définitive de ces candidats
thomas a eu un comportement inacceptable
la voix a exclu définitivement thomas de
l' aventure si la violence est banalisée
dans ce type de programme certains
franchissent la ligne jaune et sont
accusés de débordements dans la vraie
vie à l'instar du couple neruda et
ricardo qui ont été condamnés pour
violences sur deux adolescentes à deux
mois de prison avec sursis suite à une
altercation dans un bar même chose pour
marvin qui avait été accusé par un autre
candidat d'avoir été violent lors du
tournage de l'émission les princes de
l'amour ce qui lui avait valu une
exclusion du programme alors beaucoup de
violence est également de la drogue la
prostitution de la violence mais dessous
de la télé réalité je vous dis quand on
a préparé ce sujet on n'y croyait pas du
tout et benjamin castaldi vous nous
confirmer tout ça là encore une fois
moins dense y avait des il y avait une
sécurité il ya eu quelques altercations
qui était énorme il est fixé et les eaux
il ya une fois la coupe vsam sa mère et
sa fille qui était là pour le secret je
suis là avec ma maman est vrai que la
première soirée a dégénéré parce qu'il
va encore un peu trop d'alcool
d'ailleurs depuis cet épisode là on a
supprimé quasiment l'alcool et ce mec ça
a dégénéré
bon ça c'est la vérité après honnêtement
entre ce que je faisais moi et ce qui se
passe dans votre temps vos émissions cdm
le monde bisounours ans c'est les
bisounours
j'ai juste une info par exemple sur
l'alcool qui est assez importante
justement parce que du coup ça mène à
des violences à l'époque je j'espère que
tu vas pas contredire c'était deux
bouteilles de champagne pour 22
candidats c'est quand même pas énorme
donc la production faisait attention à
ce qu'ils ne boivent pas trop alors
qu'aujourd'hui dans des émissions comme
les anges mais la 14e allemagne à deux
chiens et pendant ces deux jours off
c'est là qu'ils vont se fournir en
alcool et tout ça et du coup après ça
boit h24 mais ils sont très surveillées
pendant 20 jours
benjamin dit la vérité il y avait de
l'alcool qui circulait qui je sais que
mon m'a dit qu'il avait d'alcool même
paraît que la production donnée un peu
d'alcool aux ânes on a maintenant
attendez je vous dis la vérité au début
de télé réalité le principe de base
était ou alors donné à l'alcool comme ça
ça va bien se passer bon se détendre il
va se passer ce qui doit se passer mais
quand il ya eu quelques débordements et
des incidents on a évidemment réduite et
sur la fin je vous jure qu'à la fin
c'était un vrai problème de gestion
parce qu il râlait les candidats n'ont
aidé à une bouteille pour 23 qu'est ce
qu'on fait de nos soirées d'accor gilles
sur la prostitution suspendit à une mise
en examen en juin 2018 pour proxénétisme
c'est très lourd d'une ancienne
candidate les enquêteurs ne disent rien
ils travaillent donc ça sortira bientôt
alors justement les candidats trouvent
de nombreux moyens pour gagner de
grosses sommes d'argent après des
émissions de télé-réalité booking
réseaux sociaux va vous parler du
business des candidats parce qu'ils
gagnent énormément d'argent
après avoir fait ses émissions gars si
les émissions de télé réalité ne sont
pas connus pour apporter beaucoup
d'argent à leur candidat cela leur
permet une belle exposition qui se
transforme en une autre monnaie bien
plus rentable le nombre de followers
mélanie 418 milles sur instagram manon
marceau des marseillais 1 million
et un million neuf pour julien tanti car
aujourd'hui c'est là que se joue la
guerre avec les placements de produits
et les contenus sponsorisés les stars de
la télé réalité peuvent se faire
d'énormes cacher alors que pour leur
participation dans les émissions il ne
touche que quelques milliers d'euros
certains d'entre eux arriverait a gagné
près de 100000 euros mensuels grâce aux
réseaux sociaux un business si juteux
qu'il attire énormément de candidats pas
toujours regardants sur la qualité des
produits qu'ils mettent en avant ces
dernières années plusieurs polémiques
ont éclaté suite à des produits de
mauvaise qualité vendus à des prix
exorbitants sous le prétexte de fausses
promotions et vous êtes vous choqué par
ces pratiques alors un mini vous nous
confirmer tout ça les placements de
produits s'appelle beaucoup ont
notamment les tournages on était la
journée à d iliad il ya des stars de
télé réalité elles peuvent gagner
combien par mois avec ses placements de
produits ou des 100000 ça me paraît un
peu et c'est sans parler jusqu'à 100 mm
mais ce chiffre est vrai j'ai une info
il ya même une candidate qui a refusé
les 100000 euros parce qu'elle avait
mieux ailleurs
ah oui mieux que cent mille euros par
mois ce sont 1000 euros par mois à peu
près mais le mérite c'est le plus connu
mais à sa star des réseaux sociaux c'est
maintenant des sahraouis y'a pas que les
fans de téléréalité il ya des bonnes et
en amérique quand l'écart descend faut
un poste elle touche c'est pas 20
millions d'assurés apprennent qu'elle
ferait une fortune ne va pas sur rue
voilà oui c'est sûr crime d'amour n'a
rien dit non non on a dit messi énorme
franchement voilà c'est ce qui se passe
derrière l'antenne quoi cette extension
on à magali bernaquez dans l'émission
s'appelle d'argent ça va ça va son
métier bien voilà c'est ça et si c'est
vrai que ses jambes sa reprise
quand tu t'exposes comme c'est que tu
mettes au visage tu mets ton nom etc
tu donnes beaucoup quand même s'ils
n'arrivent pas en tirer profit
quelque part c'est un peu normal dans
trois semaines aussi femme est la raison
dans un truc ça dépend il a raison c'est
leurs bénéfices alors les chéris moi
j'aurais juste maintenant je voudrais le
sondage
parce que c'est vrai que les dessous de
la télé-réalité prostitution violence
drogue juste derniers mots qu'est ce
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
est-ce qu'il faut arrêter ces émissions
est-ce qu'il faut trois choses qui
bougent sur certaines productions
évidemment il ya beaucoup de témoignages
sur la drogue et la violence alors il ya
une boîte de production celle qui
produit la villa les coeurs brisés qui a
mis en place une charte de bonne
conduite en plus du contrat classique
est-ce qu'il faut arrêter ces émissions
pas mal la vérité
avec tout ce qui s'est dit là les
révélations les témoignages il faut une
prise de conscience et notre jeunesse
qui en danger on l'a vue n'ont pas fait
le continent vous croyez qu'à l'ère
d'internet de nos téléphones portables
dudu du d'instagram août monde veut
savoir où se trouve l'artiste on va
arrêter ce genre d'émission
la marche de moins en moins c'est de
mettre les téléspectateurs les magazines
au dollar à 6 ans il a inclus ces
valeurs c'est non plus que ça faisait
les si les marseillais les bassistes à 1
million à une époque et basse et
dégueulasse on va pas se mentir j'ai
jamais dit que j'aimais bien les
candidats des marseillais mais ils sont
je le dis et voulez que je vous dise
quelque chose oui je je je je fais
partie du groupe
aujourd'hui les marseillais une sombre
merde
c'est horrible moi je ne jette dehors
les gars qui sont dedans parce que c'est
les gares allant très sympathique tout
ça l'émission c'est de la merde en boite
tout comme dit couple parfait ou encore
chez plus qu'hier la la villa des coeurs
brisés ou la villa des meilleurs
procession dans la téléralité mito 13%
réalité et téléspectateurs mais s'y
trompe pas voilà merci à vous